I've heard that meditation can focus the
mind and the Buddhist monks are the
experts I wangled an audience with Park
HN the meditation guru at a local temple
hall d30 in your 38 you look 28 how old
you think I am 50 maybe
oh now 43 I just had a tough life what
was the turning point for you when you
wanted to be a monk
you know see in the world I've been to
places but then the one place that I
haven't looked at yet here's my mind I
have a bad reputation for getting angry
and somewhat frustrated is there any
form of meditation that can help inside
meditation will be perfect for you
really is it an easy thing to teach to
meditate it takes time but then you know
it's good to start to get to a start
somewhere
most Buddhist men in Thailand will train
as a monk at some point in their life it
can be for three months or a lifelong
commitment meditation is a big part of
what they learn some do it for 14 hours
a day I'm going to try it for 20 minutes
[Music]
standing standing standing
right stepping
left stepping we start with walking
meditation right stepping left stepping
right stepping turn turn
apparently focusing on the movement will
free up my mind right stepping left
stepping I found it harder to
concentrate because everything was just
so slow I felt lazy ok does acknowledge
it lazy lazy lazy and then it felt
awkward awkward awkward walking so ugly
everyone is like this in the beginning a
lot of boredom a lot of laziness but
that's normal ok I'm gonna set the timer
to 10 minutes and see how it goes after
10 minutes mm-hmm eyes closed eye closed
now the big challenge sitting still for
10 whole minutes I'm supposed to
acknowledge any thoughts that come into
my mind naughty thoughts thinking
thinking thinking
food critics pon me food critics food
critic thinking thinking thinking
[Music]
we're so Godin how how'd it go
see now I feel twice as bad okay cuz I
feel like I've wasted 20 minutes how did
you manage to do that for 14 hours a day
you have to like what you do so do you
see the value in what you do thank you
I have to get up now cuz my bum is numb
excuse me I'm grateful for the lesson
but I think it's time to make a fast
getaway take care thank you
you don't mean where's the bottle
maybe he puts too much pressure on
himself on himself sometimes um if he
practiced well enough then he would be
the boss of his emotion that was a lot
more difficult than it looks
meditating you can switch off quite
easily five minutes
fine ten minutes no an hour no 14 hours
definitely not we never know later on in
life the old gray hair start pairing
yeah maybe but right now I still prefer
going for a run the north of Thailand
has been quite an eye-opener
I may not have achieved spirit
enlightenment but I do feel I'm on the
road to culinary nirvana
[Music]